[Musica]
lo scorso anno ho avuto l'opportunità di
prendere parte ad un progetto promosso
dal mio istituto in collaborazione con
camelot che è un'associazione la quale
si host si occupa di ospitare i ragazzi
profughi provenienti dall'africa sub
sahariana che hanno un'età massima di
circa 18 anni 18 anni e 6 mesi
da questa collaborazione sono nati tre
differenti laboratori un laboratorio
artistico un laboratorio sportivo e uno
musicale
io per esempio ho preso parte a quello
sportivo e da un progetto del genere
diciamo è nato il mio interesse
ovviamente per un mondo del quale non
conoscevo l'esistenza che al mondo
dell'immigrazione un mondo ricco di
problemi che bisognerebbe anche provare
a risolvere e quindi questo ma reso
anche più sensibile adesso quando
cammino per bologna cerco anche di
individuare quelli che potrebbero essere
degli eventuali problemi da risolvere e
quindi il mio progetto si basa proprio
su dei problemi che io ho notato essere
presenti sul territorio
in realtà non si basa solo su due
problemi ma anche su un opportunità i
tuoi problemi sono la presenza di
numerosi edifici che non vengono
utilizzati presenti sul territorio e
dall'altra parte appunto il problema
dell'immigrazione
molto spesso non vengono trovati edifici
dove poter ospitare questi ragazzi e la
cosa sembra un po un paradosso perché da
una parte abbiamo un esubero di
strutture non utilizzate e dall'altra
invece ceneda necessità vorrei proporvi
due numeri che sono 4,1 milioni e 11,2
milioni
uno di questi è il numero delle case che
non sono utilizzate presenti sul
territorio europeo e l'altro indica il
numero di persone che non hanno una casa
sempre sul territorio europeo
secondo me il quale potrebbe essere il
numero di persone che non hanno una casa
11 milioni o 4,1 milioni
purtroppo
appunto le persone che non hanno a casa
sono 4,1 milioni e le case che non
vengono utilizzate sono 11,2 e se
pensiamo che noi in italia se a 60
milioni è più o meno un sesto della
popolazione italiana e di questo di
questi 4,1 milioni di persone
moltissime non hanno una casa perché
fuggono dal dalla propria dalla propria
città dalla propria nazione per motivi
quali la guerra la fame vari motivi e
molto spesso si vedono innalzare davanti
dei muri come purtroppo abbiamo sentito
recentemente anche di barricate o cose
molto simili nei confronti proprio dei
migranti quindi questi sono i due
problemi principali
ma qual è l'opportunità l'opportunità è
la necessità che hanno le le scuole di
fare effettuare le ore di alternanza
scuola lavoro infatti vedo numerosissime
persone che comunque hanno più o meno la
mia età o comunque chi di voi ha figli
nipoti parenti che frequentano dei licei
degli istituti tecnici sanno che le ore
di alternanza scuola lavoro da fare sono
tantissime e molto spesso succede che
non riusciamo a mettere in pratica
quello che studiamo in classe e quindi
l'obiettivo di questo progetto è proprio
quello di basarsi su questa necessità
per dar vita ad un'organizzazione
finalizzata ad ospitare i ragazzi
profughi quindi utilizzando strutture
già esistenti sul territorio e non
utilizzate quindi riducendo al minimo
anche l'impatto ambientale dare vita a
una struttura organizzata gestita
proprio dai ragazzi delle scuole quindi
per fare alcuni esempi pratici gli
studenti degli istituti tecnici già
potrebbero occuparsi della gestione
spaziale di queste strutture oppure i
ragazzi degli istituti alberghieri
potrebbero occuparsi del della mensa
della cucina la cucina a sua volta
potrebbe far affidamento sui prodotti
derivanti dai campi gestiti e lavorati
da dagli studenti
delle scuole delle scuole d'agraria ma
come potrebbero i liceali e parlo da
liceale entrare a far parte di una
struttura del genere noi iniziali
potremo mettere a disposizione le nostre
conoscenze teoriche e quindi insegnare
insegnare materie di base come per
esempio all inglese la matematica ma
soprattutto insegnare l'italiano perchè
sembra scontato noi parliamo italiano e
non ci sembra neanche quasi una materia
però è essenziale in realtà perché come
fanno questi ragazzi a comunicare con
noi se non sanno l'italiano è ovvio che
possano essere costruite delle barricate
non ci capiamo
non riusciamo a entrare in comunicazione
è più facile alzare una barricata contro
qualcosa che non si conosce
se invece noi insegniamo l'italiano
diamo anche gli strumenti a questi
ragazzi per poter entrare in contatto
con noi quindi non solo noi
trasmetteremo qualcosa loro ma daremo il
modo i mezzi a loro di trasmettere
qualcosa noi infatti dai laboratori dal
laboratorio al quale ho preso parte
entrato proprio questo che loro possono
dare qualcosa noi ci divertiamo
nello stesso modo ci arrabbiamo per le
stesse ragioni abbiamo culture
semplicemente diverse ma bellissime
entrambe quindi perché non scambiare
quello che abbiamo e quindi proprio da
questi da questi problemi si potrebbe
arrivare a un qualcosa che tende anche a
valorizzare il territorio che ospita
queste strutture
potrebbe succedere che diciamo possano
essere viste come veri e propri ghetti
perché comunque i ragazzi vivono vivono
dentro queste strutture
gli vengono insegnate le materie in
queste strutture pro se noi integriamo
con il tessuto sociale con realtà già
esistenti sul territorio
allora si va diciamo a eliminare anche
quello che è un problema di
ghettizzazione praticamente e quindi
cercando di valorizzare allo stesso
tempo ciò che ogni città può dare
si può diciamo appunto mettere
esalto qualcosa pensando a bologna per
esempio la nostra tipicità e la cucina
cioè noi siamo famosissimi per la per la
cucina quindi ci sono gruppi anche di
sfogline che sono signore che fanno la
pasta sfoglia e che molto spesso e
volentieri potrebbero aver bisogno anche
di una mano quindi perché non avvicinare
anche generazioni diverse e non solo
diverse culture
sono convinta che l'esempio di bologna
comunque possa essere applicato a
qualsiasi città italiana perché comunque
la nostra peculiarità è che abbiamo
molte città con le proprie tipicità e
quindi insomma da questi problemi
cercare di dare un proprio contributo
questo è l'obiettivo del progetto è
infatti quello che vi chiedo è proprio
quello di di credere in progetti del
genere
so che possono sembrare magari utopici
irrealizzabili
magari non pratici per o anche soltanto
credendoci investendoci possiamo dare il
nostro contributo per cercare di
cambiare anche seppur poco seppur nel
nostro piccolo il mondo in un certo
senso e quindi cercare di portare il
nostro contributo ad un eventuale
miglioramento grazie
[Applauso]